yeah no just to win it's seven out of  seven i mean completely unheard of on  board one  unbelievable cash continues still on  fire and his rating will be already over  27.20  unbelievable  will it be  yeah because he's not missing five  points from this i think he's on 27  14 now he'll be like 27  he will be like 27 uh he's only 27 14. i  already thought like he had 27 14 then  he won a game and he's winning another  one but  no no i don't know maybe in my mind i  already thought like oh yeah so it it it  somehow failed to update yeah he's 27  19 19 and playing exactly yeah that's  what i felt yeah he will be  27  23 or something yeah yeah the  2700.com just lied to me for some reason  i don't know why  [Music]  yeah wow okay i mean incredible